We're going to go, we're going to go live in five. We're going to go. Well, let's do a quick, quick cold. Let's do a quick cold. Let's do it in five. When I get down, we're going to go cold. This is how we count down to the cold open. Right.
Are you going to say one or you're just going to stop it two? I'm not going to say one. I'm also not going to say two. Old broadcast out. So I'm going to go five, four, three. By the way, you're wrong about that. You know, I've heard, I've heard you say that before. Everyone always says the two.
It's just the one that's not safe. Five. Four, three. Welcome to the cold open. Welcome to Smartless. Ah. Everybody takes. Hey, everybody.
Jay, in through the nose, out through the mouth. Park. Now we start. Hi. Hi. Hey. Thanks for coming today. Hey, you want to know?
Oh, go ahead. Oh, no. Sorry. Do you have a story all queued out there? Yeah, I just actually thought of this. Our show opened last Saturday. You know, I saw you on my Instagram-ish thing. And you were saying hi to the audience
and I immediately got a little nervous. I was like, oh my God, there he is. He's on stage, he's in front of it. He did it. So you did it, you did an initial, we in previews right now? Yeah, first preview went great, second one went terrible.
I love all the photos. You look like you're standing on the, like, the bow of a boat because you're always like standing there like looking off into the distance, you know. Simon the King of the World or something. Yeah, he's proud and he's here. Hey, tell us, okay, so tell us what was good about the first and bad about the second well you'll relate you like this kind of talk this it's talking shop you know
when you kind of connect to what you're saying it's very real and it's authentic right and then sometimes when you do a show up a million times you sometimes there's a little tiny veil between you and the yeah and so but you're doing the actions and you're emoting but it's a little manufactured yeah and that's how the second show was that's how the second show but i bet the audience i bet it didn't feel good but I bet it still was good. Sean, explain to the audience a little bit, because you told me that, you and I spoke earlier and you told me that.
And I said, well, that's to be expected. And I said that because... It's very frightening. It's kind of a known thing, right? You do your first show, and it's great. It's like gangbusters, yeah. And then there is that sort of sophomore slump. Yeah, I guess...
I wonder if it's an energy thing. Like, oh, man, I'm exhausted, right? And then maybe that's just... I don't know. And then you kind of build back up again. Yeah, but when you're standing on the stage and you're saying the words and like your mind goes blank, but your mouth keeps talking.
Right. Was it just you going through this? Or did the other actors have a good time? Was it a good show for them? How were they? Sometimes you can just rely on the rest of the team. And you know, J.B. and I and our crew were coming next week to see you. Yeah, J.B., I don't know if you know this.
This is the best news, Sean told me today. You ready? It's an hour 15. Yeah. Oh, it's a tight hour 15. Do I get to sit front row? We're at dinner before we know it. Do I get to hold the book?
Can I hold the book front row? Yeah. And be the guy you turn to if you forget a line? I would love that. And then I give you the wrong line. Or you just, you look to me and I just look up at you and I just give you a real polite middle finger. Yeah. If you gave J.B. the book, I would say this is a compliment.
You just give me a line from 12 in 10 minutes. Yeah. That's the way you would. Yeah. You would be really good at that. It's ridiculous. Yeah. But when those curtains open and the lights come on, you're like, oh, there's, I have to do this.
It's the scariest thing in the world. How was Scotty? Was Scotty a puddle of nerves? I bet he was. He looked scared. But you know what? He looked like he doesn't know what to do. I went to PT today physical therapy because I'm standing so long on stage.
And so even right now, as I'm talking to you, I have to learn how to do sit-ups. Like, you know, like you- Oh, is that what they said? Engage your core. You got to engage your core. Yeah, gauge your core. PT doctors said the middle's too soft. And you're wearing double hokas, right? You've got custom double hokas on.
Hey, why don't you get one of those cashier mats? Custom double hokas. Hooks him at the bottom of my shoes. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, cut out a couple of shoe size, shoe size cashier mats. Like snowboards. Yeah.
That's really funny. So you've got to engage, so you're doing setups. You're trying to do exercises to engage your core. Your core, so you're back, right? You guys all know that. But I just kind of haven't been doing that. Anyway, who cares? Don't get me going on core.
Yeah. Guys, someone who has a really good core is my guest today. Here we go. He grew up in a remote Australian community, four hours from the nearest town, spent his teenage years surfing. Fed income. And at one point, repaired breast pumps
in a factory for $10 an hour. He moved to L.A. to be an actor and was about to quit until one last audition, flipped the script. That's the way it always happens, isn't it? He named his son after Brad Pitt's character and Legends of the Fall, but you may know him as Captain Kirk's father.
It's the brilliant, charming. Chris Hemsworth. Hello. Wow. Hello. How are you? How are you? Hello, Chris.
Guys, this is, Chris knows my wife, okay? Oh, really? I'll leave it at that. I'll leave it at that. Well, we got to start there. You'll leave it at that and I'll pick it up from there. Chris. Wait, for real?
Yeah, they've done a little bit of part. We're partying together. Oh, what is that being? Yeah. It's getting worse. Where have you been at all those parties, might? I know. You weren't involved?
I'm so, you weren't allowed to come. I'm kind of jealous. Well, I lost my privileges years ago, and I think it's better for me to stay out of what we call trigger environments. I should probably do design. Wait, wait, what are we alluding to? What happened with the parties? I don't know.
They've got some mutual friends, and they have fun, and they create trips, and they go places. Like recently or in the past? trips of O'Connes, yeah. Yeah, I think recently, yeah. And then I, you know, I stay home and I just, I work on, I work on stuff. I do charity work, you know, and I fix the house, I take care of the kids. That's what we're watching TV now, huh? Yeah.
Can you share? Chris, hi, nice to meet you, by the way. Hi, Chris. Thank you for being here. See you guys. Can you share with us one of those vacations or trips? They're hard to recall, aren't they? Yeah, they're quite a blur.
The last one was at Palm Springs and there was about, oh, that's nice. 50 or 60 people flying out there and it was quite a big three-day event. Sounds so good. And you were missed, Jason, but we talked about it. I would have, I would have crushed me. You would have been back in the day. Back in the old days. I'd still be there.
Hey, Will, you know what, Will, it's amazing you and I never partied. I know. We did. We've been through this. We did one night. Jason doesn't Chris. Jason doesn't remember, but before our privileges were suspended. Years ago, Jason and I had a night out. I don't want to get into the details of...
But we were irresponsible in our 20s. There were moments where... We had fun. I had some fun with David Cross, too, a couple of times, too. Anyway, done that, did that. Three iPhones and cameras and you can kind of... Jason one time he took his belt off. He tried to climb a light pole once.
I was with him and David Cross, and I only stayed late because I was, like, looking out for their safety because they were both acting like ding-dongs. I remember I stole your, I had your belt for like two years. Yeah, why did my belt come off? It would happen just after that. Was I looking to self-sphyxiae?
Oh, my God. Anyway, Chris, welcome to Smarty. I want to start, like, in the intro, like, learn, I've read so much about you coming up to this, and I knew none of this. First of all, I just want to, in the intro, you named your son after Brad Pitt's character. Is that true?
Tristan? It was a... Legend of the Fall. And did you talk about it with your wife? Yeah, no. So we liked the name, and then we were sitting on the couch one day. We had a few different ideas, and that film came on. And the scene where he's on the horse and rolls into the space across the field
and couldn't look more legendary. And me and my wife, both went, oh, this is the coolest character ever, isn't it? And his name was Tristan. And I was like, what about Tristan? How about that? That could work, and off we went. How about that? That's pretty cool.
Now, has your kid grown into that name? Does he look like a Tristan now to you? He does. I mean, he's short of hair now, but he had for the first kind of, he's 11 now, for the first kind of nine, ten years, he didn't cut his hair, so it was long, blonde hair.
I mean, you really went with the legends of the fall. I didn't know if it was an influence by outdoing or whether there was some sort of... It wasn't a Halloween costume. No. Did he look like many things? Thor? He absolutely did, yeah.
And he's incredibly high energy and rides horses and motorbikes and surfs and so he fits the name. And did you ever... Did you ever meet Brad and tell him that? Not that particular story, no. I met Pat once and a big fan, obviously, and kind of had this awkward interaction
where I went for the handshake. Or he went for the handshake, I went for the hug, that kind of in-between thing. Oh, God, that. It was almost turned into a kiss, and then I was going out of the party. My God, it would slow down too slow for me at that moment. I was standing across the room, my agent was like, he wants to meet you. I'm like, no, he doesn't want to meet me, whatever.
And then eventually an hour later, I was like, oh, Brad, you're here. Oh, just trying to act all. Much on, go on. Hey, look at you. One of those. Where are you today? Are you down under? No, in New York.
I'm in a press tour for crime, one of the. one, a filmer promoting. Oh, I can't wait to see that. You know where he is, J.B. Look, you can see where he is. Oh, yeah, yeah, that's, that's right. That's our place. That light switch right there turns on the fireplace.
If you've been looking. That's what that does. Yeah, I never knew where, yeah, it's going to take a little while. It's going to click for a bit. You won't explode. Hey, that Bart Layton. I love that guy. What a great director he is.
I can't wait to see your film. I just saw it last night. It was fantastic. Oh, you loved it. Yeah. Incredible. Yeah. Add you your seat the whole time.
No notes? A couple. It's locked? They're not locked yet. Always notes. Okay. If you want to give us some really nuts off air, I can, I won't take them so personally. No, Chris, don't you want, don't you want some, don't you want to do a film next that doesn't
take, like, six months to shoot and all these sort of life-threatening stunts you've got to do? And don't you want, like, a nice, calm sort of like a, like the equivalent of a sitcom in a movie? Sure. You know, that you can just relax. Yeah. Yeah, the four, five, six months shoots are tedious. And I know you've all experienced this,
but unnecessary too, I feel like at this point. You know, like the technology, cameras and lighting and what you're doing post-production. And everything is still done how we did it. Ten, twenty years ago. Yeah. And you have, you know, 20 big trucks there full of equipment sitting there just in case,
and especially on the bigger the budget, you know. And you just stand around and do nothing. Then you do a smaller film, and everyone's, it's fast pace, you don't have the luxury to sit around and wonder, and it feels like the preparation's almost done in a far more specific way because there's such a limited time frame.
And I love that style of working. Like I grew up working on a soap opera, and it was the wood shoot 20 scenes a day. And as, you know, the scripts were not great, but you made them work. But just the momentum you get from that and the sort of just by having your feet on the ground continuously day after day,
the knowledge you gained from that, I think, is fantastic. Yeah, and learning to be good quick, right? Like, you've got to be good fast on those soap operas, yeah? Yeah, yeah. What was the soap operas? Or you learn to be bad fast, too, which is what most of what I did. Yeah, we just had Margot Robbie
and she said she was on a showdown the same one. Yeah, I did neighbors for like an episode and then I did Home and Away, which is the sort of competing one for like three years. And when Margo was on, she talked about when she moved to L.A. that there was like an Australian mafia that helped each other out kind of thing.
You know what I mean? Were you part of that? There was like a drive. I was the honest. I always felt there was the Australian Mafia kind of film industry and then the folks that had trained at Nider and I think Mel Gibson and Cape Blanchet and the big acting schools
and then the theatre group and then I was on the soap opera and I always felt a little outside of that cool mafia bubble and I remember kind of turning up to a few premieres and kind of being on the guest list but not really and having all those awkward moments and honestly when I came to L.A.,
I didn't know that whole crew of Australian people And I started working and eventually met them all and, you know, Joel Edgerton and a few folks that, you know, good friends of mine now. Love that, Joel. I always felt I was, I did this, you know, I did side proper, I did dancing with the stars, so I wasn't seen as being taken seriously.
Wow. Everyone was giving you the Brad Pitt handshake. Yeah. Did you rent a car from the Romanian guy? Margo went to the car from a Romanian dude who didn't require any ID. Oh, God, no. He said away from him. Good, yeah.
Good. No. Well, now I imagine you're fully embraced, and it's all one big party. It is. It is. Because it's, it is such a small industry, you know. And those who have had success in Australia and make the leap overseas and work, there is just such a cool gang of, you know, people in support now.
It's remarkable, again, we said it with Marco, but it's remarkable how many Australians come off those two shows and come and have huge success in this country. in the film business. It's remarkable. It really is. It's the S&L of Australia. Yeah. You know what I mean?
S&L borns so many stars. All right, so you're in New York and you're doing a bunch of press for Crime 101. I would imagine you're going to do a talk show or two, but are you noticing, are you doing like some of the content stuff that is kind of like a part of most of these press tours now? Like, Willie, I know you've got a hot wings out there.
I still haven't seen, but I'm dying too. I saw a clip some of this really fun. So, like, every, have you been doing some of that stuff? Yeah, I did, I actually did Hot Wings for a previous film, a lot of fun. Yeah. Not on this trip. How far did you get? Did you do all 10?
I did, and I was getting really cocky and kind of just more, more, more, more, and this one's not so bad. And Will, you know, by the, like, the 9th or 10th one, it's just a different game. And they just stopped recording because I was like, they had to throw up, and they got me ice cream and milk, and I was, like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And we were all supposed to get out for dinner that night. And I hadn't eaten all day. And by the time I did the show, it was the first thing I put in my stomach was just a bowl of hot sauce.
And then I just went back to the hotel room and I sat there for the next 12 hours hugging the toilet bowl. Did you sit down? I was just on the floor. Nothing was operating properly. Everything wanted to come out. Why does it? It's so, I had to take the ice cream,
and I ended up slathering it on my lips like zinc, like a surfer. Tell me slow. And then was it dripping down your chin? It was, honestly, at one point I was like, I wanted to rip, like it was spurting so bad. And I was just the whole time, I was slightly angry. Yeah, and then you enjoyed a second.
He just kept looking at Lewis Kay. By the way, I did. I called them out. And by the way, the only reason I went all the way through is because they told me, J.B., that you had made it all the way through. Sure, not a problem. Shut up.
This mouth can take a lot. Hey, but I only said one bite. enjoyable about having it that hot. Anybody wants to have that shit on their food? I know, but did you eat the whole wing? I just took one bite. No, one bite, one bite. Yeah, that's all it took.
That's a mistake. Well, Chris ate the bones. That's why you threw up. Yeah. But it was just on, I did Graham Norton with John Bishop. Oh, wow. Yeah, oh, nice. Lovely bloke.
Yeah. A fantastic film, by the way. Oh, thanks, man. He's a great dude, isn't he? He's great. He's amazing, and he told the whole story. And, yeah, we're just, what a beautiful. What a beautiful story?
The kind of thing you can't write, you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah, real life kind of shows you the better stories. I love that. What would the sequel be on that, Willie? What would be the sequel? Is this thing still on? What's going on? Is this thing still on?
What's John Bishop? Yeah, what would happen with you? You'd go to the Olympics with Laura, right? By the way, no bad pitches. Keep going. And she'd win the gold. As a coach. She'd win the gold as a coach.
as a coach, yeah. And then you guys would go on tour doing a stand-up, stand-up tour as a couple. And I'd get canceled. And I'd get canceled on tour. And then it would be, you know, what... Let's write it. Yeah, let's write it.
It writes itself. Chris, I haven't seen you since we were singing that song and that car on that crazy commercial we did. Karaoke? No, what was it? It was for a video game. For a video game. Some head-banging...
Sounds like a payday. Yeah. Yeah. And artistic, you know, integral expression, all of that. Yeah, yeah, that too. It was a crazy huge production for a video game commercial, wasn't it?
It was a mobile game. Yeah, yeah. It was, well, God, what was it called? Chris, do you play the... We had fun, though. We loved it, we loved it so much. We love whatever it was. Did you play those video games
that you need, like, a headset to play? You know, you're shooting people up? No. Really does that. No. Well, you don't still do that, do you? I don't. It's been years, actually, to be honest.
Yeah. I want to know. Sean, you're into Sonic, aren't you? The burgers or? No. Immediately to food. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show.
So, Chris, I want to know about growing up and talk to me how that started and where the first love came from. Like, what was the first thing? Also, like also an acting family, Sean. It should be pointed out. No, for sure. Well, I was getting there, well.
Well, I'm sorry. Yeah, neither of my parents were actors. My mom has more of an artistic flair. You know, she paints a lot and writes. And was interested in acting, and then she got pregnant with my older brother when she was 19, and then had me and then had my younger brother, and so we kind of ruined her dreams in that sense.
And there's three? Are there any more than the three brothers? No, it's just the three of us, yeah. There's three, yeah. And I grew up in Melbourne and then moved to Northern Territory in the Outback and lived in an Aboriginal community there. And my dad was mustard cattle and buffalo and so on. And it was the complete removal from the suburban Melbourne city life.
We were literally, you mentioned before, but four and a half hours outside of Catherine, southeast Arnhem Land. and just a different world. Like my most vivid memories and some of the most beautiful memories I've heard from us. How old were you when you left there? I was, the first time I was about four to six and then came back to Melbourne for a year
and then went back up for another year and a half. Wow. So do you know your way around a farm then with cattle and stuff like that? Could you get by? Yeah, I mean, I was young, you know. I was just kind of exploring and doing, you know. Doesn't make you on.
No, no, no, I was around it all and was sort of fascinated. I don't think he gets uncomfortable with a lot, J.B., let's be honest. Yeah. He could be surprised. Unlike me, yeah. He's, you know, he's not skateboarding around Hollywood, you know, going on dishes. I know, I'm so soft. Why am I so soft?
I'm grown up out back. But what, but did you have like, this is a dumb question, but in the middle of basically nowhere where you grew up, like, what was the impetus for, did you have a TV and you're like, oh, I want to see? that from that person on that TV show? So the first time we lived there, we were in kind of shanty-looking shacks and then a tent at one point. Like it was proper, like, out in the middle of nowhere on different cattle stations. And so no TV during that time.
The second time we had a TV, and there was a truck that would come and deliver food and supplies to the community every, you know, month or so on. And he dropped us off a couple of VHS tapes. And I remember watching as a really young kid, Terminator 1, a bunch of other random sort of things,
which are great for kids at the age of 5 or 6. Yeah, sure. And it wasn't that that inspired me, but that was kind of, I don't know, my earliest memories of what cinema was and that experience. And then I just love watching movies and not so much to be an actor.
It was more of like, I want to be Legerless and Lord of the Rings and I want to go and swing a sword and be in that fantasy world. Right. And again, not escaping what I was in my own world, but just the sheer adventure of it. And then by the time I was 18 and finishing high school,
it just became a real obsession like it does and like it needs to be, I guess. Right. And then I did, yeah, did the soap opera and then off to LA and then... Wait, I want to get back to... So the Whole Foods truck just drove right up to the community and they just opened up the back?
There was a big shed in this community. There's a lot of separate communities throughout Arnhem Land and they would do deliveries with basic sort of bits and pieces that would go into this, what was the shop, which was literally just a big shed. I did a documentary actually with my dad. that we go back to that community. And there's the same shed there from 30-something years ago.
Did it come back to you? Oh, my God. The huge sort of nostalgia. And the detail to which these places prompted, the vivid memories was astounding. Probably surprised you, right? You didn't know it was going to come back? I thought it would have changed dramatically.
And I went, oh, and I remember every little corner of the little streets we were living on. And I remember what games I was playing at what places and where I was hanging out. And there was this big freezer in the back of their shed where they kept all the cold food, which me and my mate, you should just go and sit in and, you know, eat the chocolate bars and so on because it was so hot out there in the middle of the outback. But it was, yeah, fascinating and beautiful place. And that's still, is that still home? Is that still main base for you, Australia?
Australia, yeah, Byron Bay. We live northern New South Wales now and moved back there 11, 12 years ago. It was kind of like my daughter is 13, my boys were 11, so it was right around the time. My boys were born. And it was just, we kind of set up in L.A.
And not enjoying it. You know, like nothing was shooting there. We were filming kind of everywhere else. Well, you're traveling anyway, so you might as well, I mean, it's a lot longer, but you might as well live where you want to live. Is that the idea? Yeah, absolutely. You know, you'd come home and paparazzi and all the sort of the trappings of, you know,
living in that space and move back to Australia. And that just was, it's been the greatest decision because it's such a, it's like, you know, when you come back from work, you want to go on a holiday, like coming home for me is it feels like a holiday. We have big farm and horses and motorbikes and surf and. That's so cool. Cool. And that's how, I read that's how you guys, you and your brothers grew up too, just like no helmets, writing, like no supervision, just like crazy, right? Yeah, yeah. No, not because my parents didn't care. It was just because we're...
No, right. I didn't mean that. Jesus, Sean. Jesus, Sean. No, no. We lived about 20 minutes from, like, the main sort of suburban areas in Melbourne up in the hills. and the nearest neighbor was, you know, a kilometer or two away and it was just all bushland and rainforests sort of set up around us. And so we would just spend, you know, outdoors, adventures
and playing different characters. And I think that's, to be honest, where the sort of intrigue or interest into, you know, transportation into another... Veeam, like, imagination. So then how do you go from that, from... And you have this sort of interest, and what was the first... audition. Like, what was the first thing you go? Like, I'm going to go read for that.
I had a, I did a, like a, every Wednesday night I used to drive an hour and a half into, into the city, into Melbourne to do this acting course. It was like a two-hour, you know, session where they'd record everything you did, and you'd have a little VHS tape, and, and you'd go home and watch it, and you go, wow, it doesn't look anything like I thought it would, and so it's kind of shocked at the system and trial by fire, and a pretty good sort of wake up. But you learn quick, you know, as opposed to just doing acting classes and not ever being confronted with what you're actually putting on screen. You learn a lot from watching yourself. I do about what, you know, oh, shit, don't do that again.
100%. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And all your little sort of tells or habits or things you're repeating, you're like, oh, wow, that's, I thought I was kind of in a complete different space and I'm doing exactly the same thing I did before. Right, right, right. But I got an agent, and then my first audition was, I think, the first job I got was, I think it was called The Sattel Club. It was a Canadian-Australian show about the...
Sean, you used to run the door at the Sattel Club, didn't you? Run the door! I still do. I still do just for some extra money on that. We take those easy, cheap shots. Feel free to jump in any time you think of one. It was a good show, both around horses and, you know, the horse club.
And I came in as a vet at the age of 18, you know, as a doogie house in of the vet world. That's funny. Sean would let the bears in, too, as well as... Sure. So he was a vet of sorts, I guess, in that way. Veteran, yeah. Wait, which brother got the first job?
My older brother, Luke. He worked on neighbors actually for a while as a steroid selling football. ball player. That's funny. That's quite a roll. And then... In the intro, I read that one job because you said you wanted to quit.
Like Jason was saying, it always happens that way. When you're like, I can't do this anymore. And then something in the universe goes, wait a minute, you have to. And what was that? Was that cabin in the woods? Yeah, it was. It was.
And it's funny. Is it the universe or is it this sort of you just surrender to the process? Yeah. you remove some of the desperation that may be coming out. You kind of hit fuck it. You kind of, and people can tell. Yeah.
It's kind of, it's that sexy indifference, guys. Yeah. No, what is that? What is that expression? So here's what it is. It's a bumper sticker. It's amazing. We've all know what that means.
When you're exhausted or you come in and you hung over or what? And all of a sudden it's like you just, your body just doesn't have the strength to light your, you know, you're being up with adrenaline and you're just kind of sick just in a pocket. And you're not thirsty, you're not looking, you're not desperate, you're just like, this is me, this is the way it is, take it or leave it. And there's something about that. People are like, I like that.
Which it comes through the, like, excessive sort of preparation too, you know what I mean? Like, and that was what I learned. Like, I was, then would try and replicate that by, like, not caring, which, of course, I did care. So it was like, well, how can I get to the point where I can let go? And then it was just about over-preparation and where there was no stone unturned.
Then you felt like, well, I've done everything I could. Any time I would walk into a room in audition and feel like, oh, you could have learnt these lines a bit better, or you should have done this, and then that kind of voice takes off and does all sorts of shitty things. You were falling into the trap? I used to fall in this trap of trying to pretend like I didn't care.
So acting twice. an audition. It was like the most idiotic, most exhausting bullshit thing. Like, I'm already sweating, you know, trying to pretend like I'm not going to sweat. Yeah. Wait, so just the sidebar I was going to say
the day the cabin in the woods came out was also the same day my movie Three Stooges came out. But I think you guys beat us. Anyway, moving on. This picture! Let me tell me something about this picture. This idiot. These three, the brother.
It's so stupid. They can't do it. Was it the same guy? Sean, I actually watched 10 minutes of that, like not four days ago. Thank you. What, the three stooges? Yeah, yeah. On the big screen?
You gave it a full 10 minutes? A full 10 here on the TV. And then we lost power or something like that. And so I couldn't see anymore. It literally crashed the power at your house. Jason, you mentioned before you know Bart Leighton or you just know. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm a huge fan of his film American Animals.
Yeah. And I just started pursuing him like some crazy fan after that. And he sat down and had lunch with me and humored me for a bit. But yeah, I cannot wait to see this. He's incredible. This was, I think, the best experience I've ever had in the set. And I've had some amazing times. And it kind of reminded me, to be honest, of like, Furiosa with George Miller felt like this
and Rush many years ago. And it's a thing where there's just this beautiful, he is just such a craftsman, such a master, attention to detail is beyond anyone I've ever seen. Some of those shots are incredible. The cinematography is stunning, and he wrote the script, so there's this deeper sort of understanding of every element to it. But then it's just this kind, collaborative,
humble human being, which you don't get the two come together. I was just going to say, that kind, yeah, kind leadership, right? Ron Howard on Rush, Bart on this. It just, it ends up
yielding that great input from this entire team if somebody at the top is not a monster. You should look at that. Yeah, I'm reading and reading. You should take note. Because I've heard a lot of stories
from your sets, from a lot of, I get a lot of anonymous emails. A lot of it. It's true. A lot of it's true. I'm working on it. Yeah, real groucher me.
Groucherton is your nickname. J.K., everybody loves J.K. Wait, so a couple of things I didn't know. Okay. Are we back off the sidebar or we're into mainstream question? I don't know if we have enough time for the segment, things you don't know. No, but look, you got, I love, oh, the places you'll go. Oh, yeah.
So you get, right, so when I, first of the, you got. First of all, talk about your tattoos. Then I'll get into that. So you've got tattoos, which I didn't know you've had this many tattoos. So tell us the tattoos you have. Are there a bunch of random kind of... Start with the back tat. Starts the backtip, the Holly Dibeson and the hawk.
No, no, no, no, the one on the tailbone. Low back. Low, lower. Oh, the barbed wire. The one that says, just breathe. Open for business. Oh, my God. That's hilarious.
My tattoos, so I have a Dr. Su's tattoo, my daughter was, I used to read that book to her a lot. And my mum read it to me, oh, the places we go, you'll go. And she just would draw that little character and loved it. And so I got that tattoo. Oh, I love that. Isn't that great? And then a few years later, I was like, I'm kind of sick of it. So I started getting it taken off, and I did like one laser session.
And then she came home one day, she goes, it's rubbing off. What happened to it? It's rubbing off? And I was like, oh, did you still? I thought, I don't know, I thought you were sick of it. She goes, no, I love it, I love it. So it's now kind of half-fated, you know, but it's still there. I love that.
Another, it's a bunch of my arm, actually, the little drawings that she did that I was sitting with her tattoo artist one night, and it was like 10 o'clock, and he's designing all these different things and all this sort of sacred geometry and trippy-looking stuff. And my daughter walked out and goes, Dad, I can't sleep. You're making too much noise. I'm like, sorry, sorry. And she sits down and starts squiggling. and drew the three little images here,
which one of them is, and the guy next to us goes, that's the wheel of Dharma, it's eight steps to enlightenment. So it's this, she's joined that. Oh, really? And then the five-pointed star, and, you know, so he looked at me and goes, I think they're way cool than anything we're designing, and so took a photo of that, and that's that.
And then a bunch of other sort of scrimals. And your Avengers friends, which is cool. I made disparaging remarks about people with tattoos on a podcast in the UK. You know that guy, Roma? She's hilarious. Do you know that dude over in London? Anyway, I made a sweeping generalization kind of as a bit, and I got a bunch of hate from it.
What was it? I was like, I said there's a direct correspondence between the more tattoos you have. By the way, I don't even believe this. The more tattoos you have, the more tattoos you have, the more boring you are. As all I said, it was boring. People freaked out, and I'm like, I'm just fucking around. It's like, I don't have a scientific opinion on this. I'm just fucking around.
Sounds like someone who would like a few tattoos. Would you like a couple? I would like a couple, actually. I thought you were. I don't have one. All I have are just my kids here and the inside of my arm. That's it. But I feel like I want like a thousand more.
I feel like the dam is broken. I have a million friends who are covered in tattoos. that would mean that I hate all my friends. The problem is I get sick of them, and so I'm not into them for a few weeks. That's what I'm worried about. I want to just get them all removed. But you're not sick of the ones from your kids, though.
The kids' ones that have a bit of something to it, but I've got some other ones that are like a weird sort of psychodromatry one, which looks like the Illuminati kind of vibe to it. I love all those little tiny drawing ones, you know? I think like what you were showing on your arm, like just like little doodles. Yeah, that's what I... I love that.
I want some of those. I love, you know, but then you get a lot. Do you have any of the ones I see people like on their arm? It's like, stay alert. And I'm like, do you have to look at it to remind yourself? And if you're looking at it, you're not alert. Just breathe. Just breathe.
Oh, right, fuck, fuck. Any quotes or any. I wanted JBI. I always threatened that if the Leafs win the Stanley Cup, I'm going to get my whole back of Wendell Clark, who's been retired for years, but my hockey idol, holding the Stanley Cup on my back.
I think I'm safe. now for a while. Oh, yeah. We're struggling along with you here in Los Angeles. Sean, you don't have any, right? You don't have any time. No, I've always wanted one. I was wanting like a...
Let's do one. Let's design, I'll design one for you and then you design one for me. Sean, if you had to put... If you had to get a tattoo of a snack food on your body, what would it be? Oh. You have to go.
Guns to your head. One snack food on the body. Yeah. It would have to probably... And it can't be hot dog. Can it be a twinkie? What about a Twinkiekeke? No, it would probably be a Snickers bar.
A Snickers bar. Yeah. Where would you put that? What about right on my neck? Right on your tummy, right across your tummy. That's right there's up. Lower back. Lower back.
Because that's what people will snicker. Yeah. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. So, Chris, in Crime 101, I mean, we always talk about this on this podcast, but like when people from Australia or the UK have to do these American accents and they're so good and they're so believable
and then you speak in your regular Australia it's just like I don't know what happens it's like how do you do that I could never do an Australian accent that's the hardest one right now no I couldn't do it guns to your hat I can say one word chest is chist that's all I know that sounds more Kiwi Chist
that sounds like Kiwi sounds like more New Zealand Chis Oh it does We'd say chest. Oh, you would say chest? Say aluminium, Sean. Aluminium. Aluminium.
I can do a British one. I can't do it. Oh, let's hear that guy. Let's hear that guy. I mean, I'll visit from that guy. It's, I think, I mean, most about television and film growing up is American, so there's a bit of, you know, we haven't ear for it, I guess. But I've also screwed it up many times as well. Wow.
How often will you go back in? Will you ask, like, you'll see an early cut of something and you'll ask the director, hey, could I go in and redo that line or that line? More now. I didn't even know I had the option in the past. And I see some review talking about not so favorably. And then the worst was a Scottish accent I did for something. And someone said it's the worst Glasgow accent we've heard since the fat bastard in Austin Powers.
Which is one of the greatest all-time. I was like, you've got a great job. Yeah. I love these guys on the sidelines throwing bombs. They can do it. I know. I think you're brilliant at it. And what about, and then you met,
didn't you meet Elsa your wife through a dialect coach? We did, yeah, yeah, yep, yep. It was a... Like, what was she going for? The dialect coach or Elsa? Yeah, I mean, but I meant like, why were you there at the same time? Oh, no, we were about trining separately with her, and she said, oh, I think you'd like someone else I'm working with.
And I said, oh, what, and I even looked her up and thought, oh, gee, looks lovely, sure, give me a fun of her. Yeah. Really? That was that simple. And then we went up for dinner and then I went and shot a movie and then came back at dinner
and then went off and shot another movie. So it was like we weren't together but we'd sort of been in contact for kind of eight months and then got together and very quickly had kids in marriage and all that fun stuff. But that's nice though,
that's kind of a nice slow burn though. Like you kind of like ease into it a little bit, a couple of dinners are in there and... Yeah, a bit of distance, kind of long distance. Was that a novel idea to you, Will? Just a couple of dates before you start with... Hey, man. Hey, so what else?
So you took her out to date? dinner a couple of times, is you? So Chris, your kids are now at the age where they can see how badass dad is and they can appreciate kind of like what a set is like and that that might be a fun sort of atypical work environment. Any of them getting kind of the bug to do what you do? Any interest there? Yeah, they do.
My daughter was in Love and Thunder, the last Thor film. Yeah. And she played Christian Bale's daughter. And then she's... Did she dig it? Yeah, but she was like... I asked her to, you know, I said, look, I can... Do you want to do this role?
And she goes, oh, yeah, cool, what do I have to do? And I said, I'll just read these lines. She's, no, I don't want to read the lines. And I was like, well, I'm going to record something to send to Kevin Faggie. She's like, no, I'm not doing it. And I was like, okay, well, you can't do it. She goes, no, but I want to do it. I'm like, yeah, but you got it.
This is like an auditioning. She won't read. So she finds it. finally did it. They were like, great, loved it. And then she did Avengers, and this is three, four years later. And by this point, she's so much more jaded about it. She kind of is like, it doesn't, hates the whole scene and everything. But, you know, it tells me she enjoys acting. We do one take, wide take, mostly sort of in my direction. And she gets up and goes, okay, are we done? I said, no, you're serious? And she goes, how much longer? And I'm like,
We're here all week, and you've done, like, one wide shot. And every single time we'd go back to the tent or the trailer, and they'd call us in, she'd like, oh, God. And I was like, India, you begged me to do this, you wanted to do it. And then her brothers are like, we'll do it, we'll do it, we'll do it. You're such a sook, India. And so they probably have more of, my boys probably have more of a, like, I don't know, they like the kind of, they're a bit more of a showman kind of, you know,
they like that space. How were the Russo's honor? Did the Ruses take care of her, or was Joe just hammering her with notes? Yes, heaps of a notes. Backstory and incessant on sort of the study and the preps you've done. No, not long. They're fantastic. And Chris, do your kids, I read that they critique your movies?
Do they actually write them or do they just tell you? No, they'll just blightingly tell me. Yeah, they're tough. But that whole generation, they're like, yeah, visual effects weren't as good and that one, dad. I don't ever remember commenting on it. any of that as a kid.
Yeah, my kids never like watching anything that's like five years old. That's sick and stuff. My kids came, my kids came and saw our,
are my brother that is this thing on and Abel, my 15-year-old goes, a lot better than that one the movie you did with the talking dogs. I go,
hey dude. Yeah. Did your braces get paid for? Yeah. What are you in the house you're living in? Yeah.
Pretty comfy? Exactly. Pretty comfy right now? Do your kids, do your kids give it up, Chris, well, like, if you do something great, well, they go, you know, that was awesome. No, no, they're really supportive. They're, um, they remember the first time when they were sort of realizing what it was that I did.
And the first time my son, I took him to the cinema to watch, to see Thor. And he was just running up and down the aisle. And I was like, just, just got to sit down, shoot down, and he's jumping up and down the chairs. And I was just like, you know, just trying to sit him down and holding him, behind him, on band and then i was like fuck this is my movie i'm fucking on the screen you know i'm not worried about someone's going to yell at us but i thought and then the end he was like
having so much fun he's sweating he's sweating and he's like right let's go and then so he left halfway through and he ran up and down the hallway he's like that his temperate's big but but he became obsessed with it and had a little hammer that he run around with and smash things and oh really that's true i mean that's cool
i mean that's pretty cool i get it my my my 15 old wishes you were his dad too. It's unbelievable. It's a long line of kids. But it's changing, like the 11, 13 year old time when there's a whole new vernacular and all this sort of new language they seem
to roll with and everything's got like a sarcastic sort of twist to it now because all the YouTube shit and so on. And I'll say something and they've got like, ugh, cringe. I'm like, no, no, no, no. I'm fucking cool, right? I'm not, I'm not. I'm not. I'm going to cool with dads, right? And it's like,
All right, right. It's all fighting in the distance. I love that. You know, the Avengers Doomsday, I was at Anthony Rousseau's house, and we saw the trailer. We were the first people to see the trailer. Yeah. It was incredible.
That's cool. This will be the, I don't know if you know this. This will be the 10th time you've played Thor, which is really cool. It's wild, isn't it? I know. Wow. It's wild. I mean, that's really, really, really cool.
Yeah. Oh, really? There's more? Yeah. Oh, that's great. Yeah. But it's just been the, it's been so much fun. And what I've really enjoyed is unlike, I think, a lot of what the other characters
that the scripts were given, they have had to be pretty consistent. Whereas working with Tyker on his films versus Kenneth Branagh with those films. And then from, you know, with the Rousseau's, all quite a different sort of tonal opinion, but also, let me kind of try different things because I was getting, same with my tattoos, I'd be getting really bored of the same thing and having a real need to kind of just throw it in different directions. And I was talking to Kevin about it and he said,
oh, it's cool because the audience now expect dramatic turns with the character and whatever we do next, that we've got some ideas to do something pretty unique again and hopefully be... Yeah, I was going to say, you must have ideas, you guys all must have ideas about where your characters might go. Because now you guys, I guess for a long time now, you guys have been going, there aren't comic books to write these scripts off of.
You guys have gone past those. And so do you guys, is there an... But there's also an obligation, though, J.B., within... Isn't there, like, not an obligation, but, like, because the fans are so... They know these characters so well, so you've got to handle it kind of with care. Like, you take chances.
Yeah. Yeah. But you've also got to, like, make sure that... they don't get pissed off. No, for sure, because you, I mean, you still can pull from, there's so many different stories within the comic books, and you pull from ideas and certain, you know, directions. And even within the different comic book artists, writers,
they had sort of slightly different takes as well, so there's variations. But you do have to be careful, because when we made Ragnarok, it was quite a twist, you know, and with Tiker's time. Such a great movie. And it was so fun. And there was a huge kind of like appreciation for the shift. And then Love and Thunder was kind of like a Monty Python sketch.
And we sort of took the piss probably a little much. And then there was some of that backlash, you know, that there was the real kind of, why is you a goofball and why is it this? And, you know, violently offended. And we were like, oh, we're just, you know, having fun or trying to try something different. But it is cool that there's that partnership there. though with the audience as well as the filmmaker that doesn't really exist
in other I mean maybe Star Wars there's some of that as well but um it's that part is really cool Star Wars sorry I mean if you can stick around for a couple hours Chris okay
but Star Wars wait what about like in the intro I didn't know this is total left turn but when you were growing up you repaired breast milk pumps what? Yeah I worked for Fisher and Parko
this home what do you call it, white goods kind of, yeah, fridges and so on. They also make dishwashers. Dishwashers. And they make breast bumps.
They make the, I didn't know that. And they would rent them to different pharmacies and chemists and they would come back to us and I'd have to repair them when the little belt, the motor belt would break.
It would also have to clean all the dried milk that was on them. So I'd have a toothed brush and spray and wipe. And that was my first, my first job. How about that? A lot of time to think about what else I would prefer to be doing.
Yeah, for sure. And you're a big surfer, and you do snowboarding, and it's like, by the way, is there snow there in Australia right now? Opposite. It's summer now. But I was just in Korshevall, France, last week with my family. Did you do some skiing? Yeah, a lot of skiing, snowboarding,
and kids are all doing backflips. You must have played a lot of sports growing up. Yeah, I did the 110 hurdles. That was my event. Really? It wasn't quite quick enough for the 100, but I was tall enough and agile enough for the hurdles, so it was a good combination.
What about footy? Do you play any footy? AFL football, yep. A NFL? Played for eight or nine years, and then when I was 17, I dislocated my shoulder and tore all the ligaments. And I'd been surfing a lot at the same time,
and so I'd eight weeks of sitting on the couch doing nothing, and I was like, I don't want to risk not surfing anymore. And then sort of gave that up. Must be a lot of dislocated shoulders in the NFL football. Every injury I have now that like back and things that start to play up, I swear were from like nine years of just getting belted on the football field. Like it's intense and your body would shatter if you got hit at that speed now. But running full pelt into each other, you know, I got, I'm getting two concussions,
when I was like 14, 15. I remember going to Australia, going to Melbourne and seeing a, going to an NFL match, and just watching and just seeing like the pure athleticism of these guys, running, kicking, catching, tackling, all of them, just incredible athletes. It's amazing.
Yeah, it's wild. Hey, so I'm still just in awe of your, just general manhood and exposure to elements and things like that. So down there in Australia, you've got the snakes, you got the spiders, you got the sharks. When you're surfing, have you ever seen a dorsal fin? And when you were out back just running around with your motorcycles and pop guns and shit,
did you ever see any of the snakes or spiders or things like that? Oh, yeah. Yeah. When I first moved to Byron Bay, there was a string of shark attacks, two deaths, and then one guy survived in the space of two weeks, one out the front of my house and one to 10 minutes south of me. and five minutes north. And I was like, where have I moved to?
What have I done? This is crazy. And then so for the next... She's still paddling out. Yeah, when there was other people in the water. So there was your chances. Your odds. A little better.
Your odds were a little better. But no, there was a period when there would just be choppers, helicopters going up and down the coastline and just like shark spotting. And then they have a siren on because there was for whatever reason, just this kind of feeding frenzy. Yeah, well, that's how they do it. So they fly above and then if they see it. one, there's a little siren from the helicopter?
Yeah, well, they'd tell the police, and the police would come down with a big speaker and try you to get out of the water, and everyone would sort of sit there and I'm not getting out of the water, and as each guy starts paddling it's like, oh, it's fine, fine, we'll go in. And these aren't sand sharks. The only kind of shark they've got down there are the big daddy's, right?
Yeah, they're bull sharks and great whites is the most predominant. No, thanks. What about the snakes? You saw snakes? Heaps of snakes, yeah. A lot of, like, kings. Heaps of snakes. of snakes.
King Brown, like the brown snakes, which is, you know, you've got kind of 15 minutes if you get the anti-venominy before yet. Yeah, and the brown spider is also like the most venous. The red back spider is, and then what's the brown spider? What are you physically pulling a shirt down to your name? I got to hang up. I mean, we see a lot of snakes around our house,
but also a lot of big pythons. and the pythons are really territorial and keep the bad ones away. And so you kind of, you want those ones around. Python, Python is not bad? No, no. No, they're not venomous, but they're very territorial with the brown snakes and the red-belly black snakes and the ones that are nasty. And so we don't mind having the pythons around.
The pythons aren't looking to mess you up. They're not looking to attack. No, I mean, you can, my kids will go and grab them by the tail sometimes. No, no way. How do they do their killing if they don't have the venom? Do they just their squeezers? Yeah, squeezing. Yeah, like mice and rats and they'll just swallow.
Squeezers. Squeezers. Wait, go back. Matt Damon, the first time he was asking me all these questions before they came out to Australia. That bitch. He won't even. Then he literally right. I was like, oh, you're fine, you're fine, fine. The first day he drives down the street, gets out of a car, and steps straight on a snake.
I've been there 42 years and never stepped on a snake. And, uh, and, I mean, this guy's a dummy. He's a dummy. What did the angel do? The angel buy himself a pair of boots immediately after that? Right up to the hip. And a helmet, glove. A pair of white.
Oh, my God. Wait, Chris, go back to the water for a second with the sharks. Do you still go in the water? Sure he does. Oh, yeah, I surf every day. I mean, people still surf. It's, um, again, it's like all the statistics you hear. But get hit by lightning.
You're hit by lightning. Or driving a car is worse. And I heard one that more people die in America a shaking, a vending machine, trying to get chocolate or whatever, and it collapsing on them. Now, I don't know if that's true, but it's... Sean's got a vending machine story.
He almost got cut to ribbons with an exploding glass door. Did you? Chin Chin when they were closed to early, right? I eat a lot of junk food, Chris. So, wait a minute. You know what I love about the Avengers crew? You guys all seem to be having a good time, don't they?
Every time I see you guys. Of course. You and Robert and all the whole crew, you guys are all just yucking it up. And it's kind of fun. It's a good group. It's a good group. And I think, you know, everyone had come into it, expecting kind of nothing and it was right at the beginning of, I guess,
a sort of superhero emergence, and each time one of them worked, it was a win for the others and their individual films, but then when the Avengers worked, we're like, oh, we're going to make a second one. And the third one, the fourth one, and the fourth one, and so everyone's kind of pinching themselves that we're still here and it's still working.
Yeah, it's pretty cool. And just a good group of people is such a fun. You deserve it, pal. Thanks, you really do. Great films. Thanks, you do. Chris Hemsworth, what a pleasure. Thanks for chatting with us today, Mr.
Thank you. Tell, when does Cremend, one and what? What's the release? Oh, yeah. It's already out. It's already out. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. It came out when.
When did it come out, Sean? It came out, wait, I have it. February 13th or February 12th? February 13th. No, it's pretty great. It's a character-driven crime thriller, you know. And it has a beautiful sort of suspense, a suspense with through the action,
but also through the dramatic scenes. And the way Bart's crafted this movie, it's edgy. seat pulse pounding from start to finish. It's a sick cast as well. I'll just say one of the greatest, Halliberry, you, go ahead. Barry Keegan, Mark Ruffalo, Monica Barbaro, Nick Nolte. It's phenomenal cast, but it's sort of a throwback to the highest films,
the 70s, 80s, 90s, but has a contemporary feel to it. Yeah, but it's really cool. I'm seeing it this. But I just have to say, now that I've seen it, and I'm a big fan of the movie, and of course you, that I won't, reveal anything, but when that one character gets in the car, that's all I'll say. I mean, that was really cool. No, I mean, well, you don't know where, you don't know when part of the movie, I'm talking about.
When one, that one character gets in the car. You know what I'm talking about it. Yeah, I was like, whoa, that's pretty cool. I was on the edge of my seat. I'm stuck to see that. Anyway, Chris, thanks so much for being here. Thanks for having you guys. Chris, thank you.
Yeah, thank you, Chris. Amanda would say hi if she was here. and maybe I'll make it to the next one. Please, do, Mike. I hope. Thanks, guys. All right, pal. Good to see you.
Good to say, yeah. Bye, buddy. Bye, buddy. Thank you. Peace. Bye, boy. Splendid. Just splendid.
Really good. This is a great guy. This is a great guy. First of all, great guy. I don't know what you guys were talking about. I think he was great. He was great. Big star.
Huge star. Big star. And yet so grounded. As you know, you know him a little bit. I hung up with him for a couple days. What a good dude. Humble, kind. Oh, my God.
Wait, what's 26 minus 11? Boy, that's definitely going to be something else. It's somewhere around 15. Honestly, that actually came out. 15 years. So he's been playing Thor for 15 years. That's a lot of it. I want to go back to the math question because I'm so dessert.
Is this worthy of recording, Sean? You know, we're on right now. Oh, we still. I'd say cut it, but I'd need the world to hear. that. This is our life, guys. Yeah. Okay?
Welcome to it. Listener. This is, you know, it's free to you, but it costs us a great deal. I mean, and just, you know, time, patience. Yeah, he's, he's, yeah, 15 years as Thor. And then doing all this other stuff in between. How about, how about I threw you guys at the beginning when I said it was Kirk's dad? Yeah, great job, Sean.
I mean, it's sick. Sick. What a bird. I was like, fucking, who is this? Who could have been? This guy, he's unbelievable. On the breast pump information. Right?
No, that is that. I'm, now I got to join my wife on some of these, some of these. Yeah, by the way, I want to know what all that is. Hey, guys, when you have, yeah. Oh, that's it. You're right into it, huh? Yeah. No more wrap up?
No Sean No I gotta go Wait Sean do you have a performance tonight No It's our one night off You're dark Oh good for you J.B
We're dark Yeah So what do you Then what do you end up doing tonight Where does Scotty get tonight out I'm not moving I'm not moving I'm so exhausted
That's fair to that's fair to Scotty Yeah What about this afternoon Well we might Take him for ice cream Yes or no But you know what I've been craving Lately is sushi
And now when you guys eat sushi Do you put, and you know, they come up with a side of ginger. Yeah, and usually next to it, it's a little pinch mound of green mustard called. Well, no, I think a better way to say that is what did the sushi say to the bumblebee? What's up, bee? Aye. Bye. What's up, bye.
Boy, that was a stretch. Willis sick. He just threw up his hot wings. This is terrible. That was terrible. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.